Have you ever seen this sign in a store window
and thought…
“Can they do that?”
After all, it says right on the dollar bill:
“This note is legal tender for all debts,
public and private.”
How can a business turn someone away who’s
carrying the same currency our country has
used for hundreds of years?
Are we becoming… a cashless society?
In an earlier episode, we talked about how
money is a global game of trust.
The only reason a dollar bill has value is
because everyone has agreed to pretend that
it does.
And in the last half-century, this game of
make-believe has evolved to a mind-bogglingly
abstract level.
Now, instead of hoarding paper slips and hunks
of metal as if they’re of any use whatsoever,
we walk up to a computer screen, tell it who
we are, it flashes some symbols at us, and
we walk away totally confident that we’ll
be able to exchange that digital information
for goods and services.
Pretty weird when you think about it.
Today it’s estimated that less than 10%
of the money in the world is cash, worth roughly
5 trillion in US dollars.
That includes all the stacks in all the bank
vaults, all the bills in your wallet, all
the coins in all the couches in the world.
The other 55 trillion or so exists only in
the minds of computers.
The transition isn’t actually that surprising.
After all, we moved from gold to paper because
paper is lighter and easier to carry.
Ones and zeroes are even lighter than paper
and can travel at the speed of light, so if
the object is to make currency as easy to
move around as possible, going digital is
just the logical next step in the evolution
of money.
Which brings us back to the cashless store.
Operators of these establishments claim that
eliminating cash boosts productivity and efficiency.
Employees no longer have to make change, count
bills or roll quarters.
Food handlers don’t have to touch money
teeming with bacteria and viruses.
And cashless registers present no incentive
for theft or robbery.
So if going digital only makes stores faster,
cleaner and safer, why are an increasing number
of cities and states banning the practice?
Many people believe that, as well-intentioned
as they may be, cashless stores amount to
a form of discrimination.
According to the FDIC, as of 2017, 6.5% of
Americans are “unbanked,” meaning they
have no checking or savings account, and no
credit cards.
That’s 8.4 million households.
And another 24 million are “underbanked,”
which means that though they may have an account,
they still rely on cash or money orders for
virtually all transactions.
These people are disproportionately likely
to be poor, minorities, immigrants, or the
elderly.
Opponents of cashless stores claim that for
those in these groups, this sign may as well
say, “You’re not welcome here.”
But how can they do it, anyway?
If you want to run a business, don’t you
have to accept “legal tender”?
According to the Federal Reserve… no.
Section 31 states
that “United States coins and currency…
are legal tender for all debts, public charges,
taxes, and dues.”
This has been interpreted to mean that creditors
must accept cash for any debts owed to them,
but a business owner cannot be forced to accept
cash in exchange for goods and services.
At least, not by the federal government.
Cities and states are free to make their own
regulations, and that’s exactly what they’ve
been doing.
Philadelphia, San Francisco and New Jersey
have all banned cashless stores on the basis
that it is discriminatory, and New York and
Rhode Island are currently considering similar
legislation.
Some owners are calling these regulations
“burdensome,” (which is an odd way to
describe receiving money from customers);
and they propose that instead of forcing businesses
to retain outdated practices, cities and states
should focus on making electronic transactions
more attainable for underprivileged groups.
Meanwhile, some businesses are already working
on innovations to satisfy everyone.
Amazon Go, for instance, has retrofitted its
automated checkout machines to accept cash,
and the Mercedes-Benz Stadium in Atlanta has
kiosks where you can exchange cash for a kind
of debit card you can then use to buy your
hot dogs and beer.
The fact is, people still value cash for a
variety of reasons.
For one thing, it’s anonymous.
You don’t have to be drug-dealer or gun-runner
to be uncomfortable with the idea of corporations
and governments keeping track of every dime
you spend.
And computers aren’t 100% reliable.
In 2018, a hardware failure at Visa prevented
millions of cardholders across Europe from
making transactions for hours.
And in the aftermath of Hurricane María in
Puerto Rico, cash was the only means of payment
available.
Cash is also used by many people as a budgeting
tool.
When Julia and I go grocery shopping, we leave
our credit cards at home and bring only as
much cash as we’ve budgeted, so we know
we won’t overspend.
Studies have also shown that spending physical
currency activates the pain centers in the
brain in a way that using plastic doesn’t.
This means that the more regularly you use
cash, the more frugal you’re likely to be.
Credit card companies seem to be aware of
this fact, as they’ve been major proponents
of the cashless movement, with Visa even offering
prizes of $10,000 to small businesses that
pledge to stop accepting cash as a form of
payment.
Though this issue has gotten a lot of public
attention, the number of cashless stores in
the country is still very tiny.
Far more are cash only.
30% of all American transactions are in cash,
including the majority of those under $10.
There are almost 70 billion individual pieces
of physical U.S. currency in circulation,
and that number is going up, not down.
Though many experts think a cashless society
is inevitable, it still seems to be a long
way off.
Until then, we’ll keep bringing it to the
grocery store to shop for food.
Just remember to wash your hands before you
make dinner.
And that’s our two cents!
Thanks to our patrons for keeping Two Cents financially healthy.
Click the link in the description if you'd like to support us on Patreon.